dream world time dilation zombies by way
of music video and so many baby
carriages slow motion has been around
since the beginning of filmmaking but
these scenes are proof that some moments
just shouldn't be watched in real time
the matrix has only grown in popularity
since its release in 1999. not easy
since it was already a phenomenon upon
its release as the red pill blue pill
metaphor has become a cultural
touchstone in ways both profound and
troubling but the film's pioneering use
of slow motion perhaps is what has most
contributed to its influence the
wachowskis leaned in with their
otherworldly tale of false realities and
very real threats making better use of
slow motion than just about anyone
before or since from the famous bullet
time sway surely one of the defining
moments of 90's sci-fi cinema to neo's
mini-gun attack to all those balletic
fight scenes with agent smith all are
memorable yet pale in comparison to the
original film's trademark scene slow
mode so audiences could appreciate every
nuance of its choreography the lobby
shootout wall running exploding pillars
nonchalant gun tossing by now any fan of
pop culture knows it well you may even
be able to play it frame by frame in
your head after all it's a scene that
was binged on vhs and dvd players long
before the term was coined in a
streaming service context
while being interviewed about kill bill
in 2003 quentin tarantino left fans with
a sound bite they'll never forget why
the need for so much gruesome graphic
violence why not let us know because
it's so much fun chan get it
nearly a decade later tarantino reminded
viewers of the gruesome graphic violence
he's known for via django unchained a
three-hour extravaganza of bloodshed and
heroic vengeance in the final act of the
film fed up with all he has lived and
endured jango returns to candyland
plantation mansion masterfully wielding
a pair of cult revolvers while spraying
blood and innards all over the splendid
colonial architecture jenko's enemies
desperately fire at him shattering glass
and splintering wood as the exchange
turns into a slo-mo bloodbath of epic
proportions it's a thunderous piece of
filmmaking one that indulges cathartic
violence with striking self-confidence
a beautiful film about ugly people this
early edward norton flick put him on the
map with an oscar nomination and its
slick style reflects the aesthetic of
talented troubled director tony kate who
got a start in advertising the infamous
curve stomp scene is perhaps so
effective and vividly remembered today
because of cage dramatic use of slow
motion as danny played by edward furlong
falls to his knees in horror at what his
brother derek has just done we see a
slow-motion close-up of derek's smug
expression clearly indifferent to the
repulsive injury he just inflicted slow
motion has the power to emphasize the
beautiful and the abhorrent the funny
and the frightening and the best
directors know when and when not to use
it many admired the film still
considered to be among the best of the
1990s however some critics did not
appreciate kaye's aesthetic sensibility
manola darges of la weekly wrote the
problem is that k who's used to selling
cars on tv shoots derrick the hater as
lovingly as he would a new volkswagen
the terminator was a tough act to follow
but after some seven years james cameron
went above and beyond with terminator 2
judgment day using cutting-edge cgi a
nuanced script and some iconic slow
motion inflected action sequences arnold
schwarzenegger reinforced the t800 as
his most iconic character early in the
film clad and bike leathers he strides
through a mall carrying a box of roses
under his arm as he scans the area the
t-800 is not looking for his valentine
he's looking for john connor the savior
of humanity he is assigned to protect
and the rose box is not a romantic
gesture but rather a tool for concealing
his lever action winchester shotgun all
of this is revealed to us in an icy cool
slo-mo sequence as the t-800 locks loads
and blows several holes into his
malleable nemesis the t-1000 played by a
sinister robert patrick as we walked
along the flat block marina i was calm
on the outside but thinking all the time
the flat block marina scene in a
clockwork orange ranks among the most
famous uses of slow motion in both
stanley kubrick's career and wider
cinematic history shot on a grimy estate
in tim's mead southeast london the sight
of alex the large thrashing kicking and
cutting his drugs is scored by
rosalini's thieving magpie which gives
the scene a dark elegance as he
reasserts his alpha male status the
psychopathic charm of alex played by
malcolm mcdowell stirred a great deal of
controversy in the united kingdom with
the press alleging a series of copycat
crimes kubrick consequently withdrew the
film from uk cinemas and eventually all
home media the ban was revoked 27 years
later following kubrick's death in the
spring of 2000 kubrick employed slow
motion in several other films most
notably the dawn of man sequence in 2001
a space odyssey and the bloody elevator
nightmare of the shining
one of the most arresting openings in
cinematic history francis ford coppola's
use of slow motion and the introduction
to apocalypse now has left a lasting
mark on popular culture walter murch the
editor of apocalypse now explained at
that time it was the biggest explosion
ever staged for a film in fact it
probably is still the biggest because
now you would do that explosion
digitally the scene's grand staging is
symbolic of the film's infamous
production which was a 238-day ordeal of
drugs set-destroying typhoons actual
real combat from filipino insurgents and
medical emergencies as depicted in the
documentary hearts of darkness coppola
even staked his california estate to
fund the film which wound up costing
over 30 million dollars reportedly some
18 million dollars more than a director
had expected it's hard to locate the
best use of slow motion in john woo's
1992 masterpiece hard-boiled because the
entire film is essentially one massive
action sequence complete with some of
the finest stylized violence in world
cinema history there are three
highlights the opening tea house
shootout the warehouse shootout and a
climactic hospital shootout which lasts
for about a half an hour there's a
notable skirmish on a dock too each
sequence is full of truly promiscuous
use of slo-mo with chao yun fat taking
out the trash in bloody balletic fashion
his enemies almost pirouetting as he
blasts them with a small arsenal of
firearms this level of stylized violence
may sound distasteful but wolves films
are far removed from reality and his
inspirations are fanciful he told the
guardian in 2001 i was very influenced
by musicals like singing in the rain and
west side story and dancers like fred
astaire and gene kelly they have the
rhythm of life i shoot action scenes
just as though they were dance sequences
i love ballet i love dancing
inspired by the 2000 ad comics dread is
a film in which slow motion is actually
a plot point set in make a city 1 a
grimy place stretching from boston to
washington dc the world of dread is a
police state racked by crime and
addiction and the drug of choice is a
sedative called slomo administered by an
inhaler the drug slows users sense of
time with immediate drastic effect
sending them into a surreal hypnotic
state in which everything occurs at a
fraction of its normal pace we
experienced their altered consciousness
with many ultra slow motion sequences
which were all shot on phantom cameras
at 4 000 frames per second according to
special effects supervisor max bulman
the photography is at its most
ghoulishly dazzling when dred throws
mama the lead villain hundreds of feet
to her death before he administers his
summary justice he has mama take a hit
of slo-mo the very drug she has been
guilty of dealing defense noted
i am an exceptional thief mrs mclean and
since i'm moving up to kidnapping you
should be more polite after receiving a
bullet from john mcclane's gun hans
gruber falls through a window of
nakatomi plaza then after a tense
struggle to release his grip from harley
mclean's wristwatch he falls to his
death hundreds of feet below han's death
and die hard has aged very well
especially when compared to robocop
which was released just a year prior in
robocop the villain falls from a
skyscraper in real time using
harryhausen-style stop-motion effects
undermining the scene's impact for a
modern viewer through green screen in
slow motion die hard had no such
problems suspended from a wooden frame
in a california studio alan rickman
dropped some 40 feet onto an airbag but
perhaps the most inspired idea came from
stunt coordinator charlie paterni who
told rickman he would be released on a
three count then dropped him early
minting that unique look of horror and
surprise on the actor's face
the slow-motion ied detonation in
catherine bigelow's the hurt locker
featured heavily in promotional
materials for the film and with good
reason the scene combines documentary
realism with an attention to detail
that's stylized yet not at all
aestheticized instead of achieving some
kind of kick-ass sensibility the scene
highlights the sickening danger faced by
bomb disposal units we see how the
sudden release of energy tears through
the immediate surroundings rocking
everything in its path as always there
have been detractors and not
unreasonable ones either speaking with
npr a rock veteran paul rykov said very
seldom is a guy going to put on a bomb
suit and walk down there and try and
dismantle something by hand he continued
it just doesn't make sense for the most
part they're going to use robotics
they're going to use other types of
explosives to set off a charge a control
charge next to it it's really a
hollywood sensationalized version of how
eod operate so maybe the hurt locker
isn't quite as realistic as many
believed it to be but its use of slow
motion undoubtedly impressive thanks to
the use of multiple eaton s 16
millimeter cameras and a director with a
knack for nerve shredding action
raging bowl features martin scorsese's
most powerful use of slow motion and he
uses it to convey metaphor personality
and sheer brutality the first instance
is the film's opening which shows jake
lamotta shadow boxing alone in the ring
as mazgani's intermezzo plays this is a
gorgeous shot but it is also a metaphor
for lamada's vicious demons which
isolate and destroy him slow motion is
used again to convey lamada's jealousy
in a social situation slowing the frame
just slightly as the boxer leers at the
men schmoozing with his partner vicky
lastly and perhaps most notably scorsese
employs slo-mo to emphasize the
head-bashing brutality of lamada's
profession the sport of boxing in the
1940s an era of bi-weekly matches and 15
round bouts perhaps the defining moment
of scorsese's slow motion
expressionistic style comes in the final
fight between lamada and sugar ray
robinson which sees lamata take a
merciless beating after the ref stops
the fight a defiant lamada approaches
robinson the frame rate slowed and says
with his face beat into a bloody pulp
he never got me
[Applause]
never down me down
no slow motion list is complete of
course without a nod to the early 80s
cultural phenomenon that was chariots of
fire the 1981 olympic drama best
remembered for a shot that almost
single-handedly wanted the oscar for
best picture the opening subtle use of
slow motion complements the rousing
vangelis score making such an impression
that the film became a widely imitated
icon of popular culture some 40 years
later it's still impossible to imagine
anyone running in slow motion without
the film's theme playing behind them in
2012 director hugh hudson explained the
film's appeal to the guardian saying
everybody remembers the opening jogging
scene along the beach it was key to
establishing character harold abraham's
gaunt and determined eric little
scottish blonde open and free aubry
montague the amiable faithful old dog
lord andrew lindsey the aristocrat
running for the fun of it
brian de palma's classic 1976 adaptation
of the stephen king novel remains
unequal despite the occasional
unnecessary attempt to remake a movie
that was perfectly good the first time
around he utilized slow motion in the
opening locker room sequence to lull the
audience into a false sense of security
via sexualized voyeurism which takes a
sudden turn when carrie discovers she's
having her first period and thinks she's
sick or dying having never been educated
about menstruation by her overbearing
mother her cries for help are mocked
cruelly by her peers and as she lies
humiliated on the shower floor we see
the first glimpse of her telekinetic
power in an exploding bulb in many ways
this scene is a lot like the climax when
carriers crown the prom queen slow
motion gives the scene its emotional
resonance appropriate for the heightened
feelings and sense of significance in
the high school world it only would have
been a few seconds of real time but we
dwell on carrie's long moment of pride
and happiness the leering anticipation
of those who scheme against her the
mounting suspicion of her friend sue the
fall of the bucket of pig's blood and
finally carries confusion and
humiliation as she looks over the sea of
mocking laughing faces for carrie this
is the moment of true horror a moment
the palmer executes perfectly then of
course time catches up with us as carrie
unleashes her telekinetic revenge upon
those who tormented her portrayed by
dipalma with the now little used split
screen technique and sharp and reaction
shots of actress [ __ ] spacek this
wonderful contrast gives us the feeling
the game has changed what would have
been a completely chaotic scene overall
if shot in real time is instead allowed
to linger for the audience to truly
understand carrie
people would think i was known for slow
motion i like slow motion i don't really
like slow motion that much
zack snyder himself may not think so but
he is notorious for his slow motion
shots and it does get a bit gratuitous
at times he's long been enamored with
the technique known as speed ramping in
which the camera speed goes slow then
fast and slow again undoubtedly cool
when you first started using it but now
you're left with the impression the man
just likes slow motion because it makes
things look cool still there's one use
of slow motion by snyder we think was
incredibly appropriate and it may not be
what you think while slow motion showed
up plenty in watchmen it was to be
expected from snyder in the action
sequences and tastefully used for world
building in the intro but it's the slow
motion used in the scene of the
comedian's death that's most significant
while the film scene was much more
elaborate and super heroey than in the
original comic the lingering death shot
as the comedian is tossed out of the
window is an appropriate reflection of
its significance in the graphic novel
this killing was the catalyst for
everything that was to come in the
graphic novels universe the central
moment around which the narrative was
spun this wasn't merely a stylistic
choice it had narrative weight and it
was well done
one of the most influential slow-motion
scenes in film history comes during
arthur penn's 1967 film bonnie and clyde
in which the eponymous anti-heroes are
cut down in an ambush by law enforcement
penn opted to film the bloody end to the
protagonist in slow motion to install a
ballet quality to their deaths something
little seen to that point but frequently
imitated afterward pin and his crew
captured the scene on four different
cameras running at different speeds and
used rapid cutting in the editing room
to create a dreamlike but realistic
sequence in which time becomes elastic
this was perhaps the first use of a
combination of slow motion multi-camera
filming and montage editing by an
american director the results speak for
themselves creating a shocking montage
of emotions suspicion confusion
obliviousness realization and horror
followed by violent death and a slow
lingering over the aftermath in an
interview with npr penn would go on to
say the scene was influenced by media
reports and images of the vietnam war he
also said the intention was to get this
kind of [ __ ] motion of genuine
violence and at the same time the
attenuation of time that one experiences
when you see something like a terrible
automobile accident sure there's a lot
more going on in the scene than just
slow motion the direction acting editing
and special effects flow together to
create a scene that would influence
american cinema for decades to come
despite being a miserable failure at the
box office and almost universally hated
by critics the boondock saints made
millions in video and dvd sales as a
cult classic how can we explain this
perhaps the single biggest point in
favor of the film is the frenzied
bewildering performance of willem dafoe
as the flamboyant fbi agent pursuing two
twin vigilantes sure he relentlessly
choose every scene he's in sure he plays
a character so bizarrely stereotypical
he manages to come out the other side as
completely unique but it works and this
can best be seen in the scene oft
referred to by the line there was a fire
fight
the slow motion in the scene is
completely gratuitous and dumb but
paired with defoe's narrative speech his
deranged dancing and the orchestral
score the scene takes on an almost
beautiful folklorish quality is it dumb
and is the slow motion unnecessary
yes and probably but it'll live through
the ages
while slow motion is often used to build
tension or create beauty in action films
inception is one of the few examples
where it actually has an in-universe
justification to go along with the
explanation of it just looks cool one of
the key plot points in the film is the
aspect of time dilation between levels
of the dream world with each layer down
operating 20 times faster than the one
above this is most obvious in the scene
which flashes between the unconscious
dream operatives in a van crashing into
the water while joseph gordon-levitt
fights assassins in a hallway and the
rest of the team escapes his snow
fortress the use of slow motion and
extreme slow motion is justified not
only by the style but also by the
substance of the story a rare treat it
was no easy feat either the van's slow
descent took months of filming which
involved the actors breathing underwater
through scuba gear and maintaining
composure while sinking into the water
as well as shooting the van off the
bridge with a cannon inception came out
in a period when slow motion was almost
overused in the post-matrix early snyder
world it's a testament to christopher
nolan's craft that he was able to use
such a dated technique and elevate it by
having the effect serve the narrative
rather than the other way around in an
interview with kcrw nolan admitted to
having never really used slow motion
before as it seemed a purely aesthetic
choice and he couldn't figure out what
it really meant with inception he found
the way of taking editing techniques he
enjoyed and incorporating them as a
literal part of the story universe
david fincher isn't a director who likes
to overindulge in slow motion but he
used it with panache in panic room in
this scene meg altman leaves the safety
of her panic room to make a dash to grab
her cell phone while her would-be
abductors are bickering downstairs the
scene is shot in slow motion with a
minimalistic musical score both of which
flow together to enhance the feeling of
urgency and danger in a situation like
that it would seem so hard to move fast
enough and seeing meg's desperation in
slow motion like she's fighting through
danger as it lurks nearby ratchets up
the tension and suspense shot in real
time you would expect the scene to
feature a lot of quick cuts and a
frenetic score fincher's choice to go
slow helps the audience absorb the
nuance and detail of the scene and truly
feel her panicked fear which is exactly
what you want in a thriller really
setting the rules for a zombie universe
or a horror comedy is important so you
may as well do it with some style ruben
fleischer a first-time feature filmmaker
when he directed zombieland was thrilled
by the opening sequence as a montage in
the script and hoped to visually develop
it further luckily the production had
access to a phantom digital camera able
to capture 1000 frames per second the
slow motion allowed the production to
give the death and gore a kind of beauty
along with the world building making it
one of the more entertaining opening
credit sequences the use of metallicas
for whom the bell tolls works so well
it's uncanny it's easy to be skeptical
of a director like flasher with his
history and music videos and the
sequence could be seen as overly
stylized but it packs a punch and helps
to set the tone for the rest of the
movie which can never be accused of
taking itself too seriously
there's nothing quite like a baby
carriage falling down a flight of stairs
to create the feeling of oh god no that
slow motion is best applied to so when
our old friend brian de palma employed
it in his 1986 film the untouchables it
made perfect sense mobsters shooting
each other up in the middle of union
station while a baby pram teeters toward
doom as a no-brainer for the slo-mo
treatment and when combined with the
palma's eye for tension and precise
camera work and editing it becomes an
instant classic there's more to the
story though the inspiration for the
scene was undoubtedly the 1925 soviet
propaganda film the battleship potemkin
their director sergey eisenstein didn't
actually use slow motion but rather a
series of rapid cuts away from the wheel
of the baby carriage teetering over the
edge of the step fooling the viewer into
thinking the scene is happening at half
speed the scene would be played for
laughs and naked gun 33 in the third
when leslie nielsen fails to save four
baby carriages toppling down the stairs
it just goes to show you whether you're
making soviet propaganda a gritty crime
drama or an absurd satire if you push a
baby down the stairs you have to show it
slowly
wes anderson has a highly distinctive
style notable for quirky themes
recurring cast members symmetrical and
pov shots retro soundtracks and fearless
exploration of the color palette slow
motion is a technique anderson's return
to repeatedly particularly in scenes
where his characters are walking this
gives anderson as director great control
and precision over the scene and imparts
emotional depth and pathos in the hands
of a lesser director it would be corny
but anderson makes it his thing anderson
often uses slow motion to indicate a
change in a character's mindset or
perspective as in the funeral scene in
the darjeeling limited or the meeting of
siblings richie and margo in the royal
tenenbaums the use of slow motion to
deepen theme and meaning is deliberate
and controlled and in anderson's hands
it's memorably successful his
understanding of the rhythm of scenes
helps him make use of slow motion with
great care so as not to eject the viewer
out of the film in fact he often uses it
at the beginning or end of his films to
allow the audience to release emotional
tension and signify a closure or
character development check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you